Only if you put that baby gravy. She corrects. Only if you put
that baby gravy in me, then you can do whatever you want to me.
Oh my god. Male. Male. Male. I just showed that to my friends
at dinner. The picture of the vagina. You're my daddy. If you
got a snow bunny, that makes you a snow dummy. If you got a snow
bunny, that makes you a snow dummy. Then you got a snow bunny.
That makes you a snow dummy. On the plane. On the plane. Stop
talking. On the plane. On the plane. On the plane. On the plane.
On the plane. On the plane. On the plane. 10 minutes later. On
the plane. He's on the plane twice. You know I do, Daddy. And
a big black baby. Dude, I think he gets it. I look like I'm pregnant
with your big black baby. She has a real obsession with these
big black babies. This is weird. This is actually starting to
get odd. Okay. Is she planning to start like a football team
or something? What is What the [__] is she saying?
So, the hits keep coming, y'all. Every time there's a town hall
held by a Republican politician. We need a black, not a white.
Get me Shannon Sharp stats. Goodbye, Kyle. Goodbye. Goodbye.
Goodbye. Hello, music. Okay, let me open up my docket. We are
right there.
Initial story. Let's give it a quick read. Uh, is this not going
to work? Cool. NFL champion Shannon Sharp sued for assault. Oh,
Hassan is bad. Sorry. Those don't pop up for me. If you guys
do Hassan is bad donations, those don't pop up ever. And there's
there's my black. There he is. Let's go. Shannon Sharp, a Super
Bowl champion and host of popular a popular podcast, has been
accused of sexual assault in a Nevada lawsuit. The lawsuit was
brought by a woman who alleges Mr. Sharp used his fame to manipulate,
control, subjugate, and violate women. Oh my god, never heard
of that before. The Accuser, who who was 19 at the time he she
met Mr. Sharp in 2023, says an illegal filing that the pair had
a nearly 2-year relationship, during which Mr. Sharp was aggressive
and allegedly raped her. Mr. Sharp has denied the allegations
and said he is the target of a shakeddown. The suit seeks more
than $50 million, 37.6 6 million pounds in compensatory and punitive
damages. The accuser is the only person suing and does not provide
details on her accusation that Mr. Sharp hurt her hurt more than
herself. Oh, yeah. Yeah, just one person. According to the suit,
the woman met Mr. Sharp, currently aged 56, in a Los Angeles
gym and had a rocky consensual relationship.
After many months of manipulating and controlling plaintiff,
a woman more than 30 years younger than he, and repeatedly threatening
to brutally choke and violently slap her, Sharp refused to accept
the answer no and plaintiff despite her sobbing and repeated
screams of no, the complaint alleges. Yikes. The woman alleges
that Sharp her as recently as January. In addition, she alleges
in the suit that Mr. Sharp insisted on recording some of the
encounters, sometimes without her consent or knowledge, shared
the videos with his friends and associates. Oh Jesus. Well, uh,
Mr. Sharp has 4 million subscribers to his Club Shay podcast
and is reportedly in negotiations on a hund00 million deal for
his network of shows. This is a shakedown, he said in a video
post on Instagram late Tuesday, addressing the lawsuit. I'm going
to be open, transparent, and defend myself because this isn't
right. Mr. Sharp then accused the woman's lawyer, Tony Busby,
who will remember from the terrible, okay, the terrible looking
accusations against Jay-Z where he was kind of coaching the woman
in in terms of the allegation, right? We covered that on the
stream. Uh, apparently this guy also represented all of the women
who accused Deshun Watson. Do we remember when Deshun Watson
got his New Deal derailed by the NFL? Yeah, he represented all
the women from that as well. Mr. Busby represented a plaintiff
accused rapper Jay-Z of misconduct and ultimately rescended her
allegation. He also worked with several female NFL star Deshan
Watson of assault. Oh my god. Donated $3 Ruben with a thing say
biscuits on the BBC website. I have no idea what you're talking
about, but thank you. Thank you, Reuben. Ruben, for the $3. Oh,
I believe he's going to release a 30 secondond clip of his tape
that tries to make me look guilty and playing to every stereotype
you could possibly imagine. Well, are you just going to quote
the whole thing? We're going to watch this, so we don't need
to quote it. Last year, Mr. Sharp live streamed audio of an intimate
encounter and his to his millions of followers on Instagram and
later apologized, saying he had mistakenly turned on the app's
live feature. Mr. Sharp played in the NFL for 14 years and won
three Super Bowls. He went on to be inducted into the Pro Football
Hall of Fame and has had a long sports broadcasting career. Shannon
Sharp, of course, is the infamous tight end from the Denver Broncos,
Hall of Fame tight end. Uh, won a Super Bowl. I think he won
a Super Bowl with the Baltimore Ravens as well. Uh, he was a
fantastic tight end. Okay, he's one of the best. His brother
was way better than him. His brother had injury issues, though.
What is it with these pro- athletes, okay? These these black
men who refuse refuse to date black women. What is the deal?
What is the deal? I think I got sent this by DJ Denkey. There's
a lot of propaganda around this. Okay, in this segment we have
an open and honest conversation about black athletes and dating.
Can I play for our second half hour of the factor on censor tonight?
Black D1 athletes are on heavy scrutiny after viral video goes
in on how some prefer to date and marry white women over black
women. Why are all these black college athletes that are getting
drafted having white women? What's going on? I am going What
is going on? They don't love their black queens. what the to
tell you as someone that is friends with a lot of D1 football
players and D1 basketball players. I'm going to tell you because
they have told me y'all five of my guys that play on division
one power five football teams and they start they were like good.
That's just false in his case. He has black kids. Well, hold
on. He did have black queens. Sure, sure. Sure, sure. But he
was messing around with snow bunny. Okay, he was playing in the
snow and that comes from for a black man straying that comes
from straying from God. Okay, he strayed from God. You know the
type of NIL deals we got. One of my man said, "Bro, I was messing
with this black girl. She heard about the deal I got and started
to request money. Apple pees and cash apps for her hair and nail."
Yo, you just got a you just got a deal. You just signed with
a you just signed with an NFL team. We going to Applebee's. I
need an Applebee's gift card stat. Get me an Applebee's gift
card now. My other friends were saying, "Bro, I would try to
take her out to Chipotle, Cava, this and this and that." She
would get mad talking about why are we going to steak? You're
good for it. I said, "Oh." They were like, "Bro, the white women,
they're down to go and get a cup of coffee, go and get some ice
cream." My friends were like, "Bro, the white women we're dating,
they pay for a lot of our stuff." I said, "What do you mean?"
They said, "Bro, they know that we're making some money, but
while we're at practice or we're at camp, they got us our favorite
Cava Bowl. Double chicken, right?" Double chicken. Amazing, dude.
The snow bunnies know when to fall in line. Okay. White women
are so stupid. I I mean, no and yes and no. Let me close some
tabs here. Get some tabs out of here. Get some tabs out of here.
All right. They aren't even pros yet. NIL is the players getting
paid in school. Oh, okay. All right. That was just a little meme
that I got sent that was very funny. Okay. We're going to have
other memes as we go through this. Let's listen to Shannon's
statement. When when he first got wind of this, he made a statement.
Oh, hold on. There's one other thing. Did I miss it? No, I didn't.
Speak to you. Okay, hold on. Hold on. No, let's listen. Let's
Let's watch this first. to my family, friends, supporters, and
colleagues. I want to This is Shannon. When he first realized
he was getting blackmailed, he came out and instead of like waiting
for the lawsuit to drop even, he just made a statement to you
directly and from the heart. This is a shame. I'm going to
transparent myself because this isn't right. This is all being
orchestrated by Tony Buzzley who has targeted Jay-Z. I will say
Shannon keeps getting in trouble. He just Shannon, you got to
keep your nose clean. Shannon is going to make so much. Shannon
is like, how do I explain this to people who don't watch sports?
People love Shannon Sharp. Shannon Sharp is awesome. Okay, but
he just won't stop getting like controversies. Honk needs to
sit his freaky ass down somewhere. He does like he needs to just
stop for two seconds. Yes, he is a like the only black on TV.
Okay, he is a very impressive black.
Tony Busby targets black men and I believe he's going to release
a 30 secondond clip of a sex tape that tries to make me look
guilty and play into every stereotype you could possibly imagine.
That video should actually be 10 minutes or so. Hey Tony, instead
of releasing your edit, put the whole video out. I don't have
it or I would myself. You know what happened and you're trying
to manipulate the media. The encounter in question took place
during the day at her invitation. And now that appears to be
a deliberate setup coordinated by Gabby, also known as Carly
on Only Fans. Gabby and Tony Busby want $50 million. What they're
getting is sued for defamation and trying to take me down. So
from so basically they they came to him, they said, "Hey, we're
going to file this civil complaint unless you want to settle."
And from what I understand now, this is the only thing that makes
me wary of his side here because I I do like Shannon Sharp, but
apparently they offered to settle for like $10 million. And to
me, I'm like, bro, that is that is an insane amount of money
if she's just making this up, right? That's crazy. My career
is all about real talk and honesty. I know my family and fans
know exactly what this is about and I'm going to be out there
telling you whatever I need to say just like I always do. I love
all you guys. Thanks, man. This will get trust me, we'll be like
back and forth on this. It gets it's pretty crazy. Okay, it's
pretty crazy. So, let me go to the TMZ. There's a couple TMZ
articles I grabbed that have like the text and some other stuff.
I'm There might be like better getting the exact precise timeline
on this is a little difficult. So this is from the 22nd, right?
Shannon Sharp offered at least $10 million to accuser. That's
nuts, right? Release the whole tape is kind of giggy, Chad. Well,
I think what he's saying is so basically Shannon's argument here
is going to be we had like a sort of BDSM type relationship.
That is his argument. And like yes, she was saying no, but she
didn't really mean no. And like if you release the whole thing,
you'll see us like talking through some of these things. It'll
make more sense, right? Uh Lanny J. Davis, who's representing
Sharp and ESPN's personality, ESPN personality civil assault
case against Jane Doe, said in a meeting with reporters Tuesday,
the proposal was doled out during mediations with the plaintiff
within the last month or so that $10 million was offered. The
one of the some of the other things that I'm not loving here.
Um I believe Shannon's camp has done the same thing that uh our
buddy Destiny did that she filed this woman filed as Jane Doe
and I think they just totally vi violated that, right? They just
like they publish her name multiple times which kind of sucks.
You're not not a huge fan of that, right? Check this out. You
and Shannon offered to settle these
Uh yes, there was a settlement offer made by Mr. Sharp. I will
only generally say to you that it was in the tens of millions
of dollars demanded by the plaintiff
in return for her silence. That's under any definition commonly
understood. That is blackmail. And Mr. uh Sharp was willing to
pay an amount in the tens of millions of dollars, but no final
agreement could be reached. Ah, dude. Really? He was willing
to pay tens of millions of dollars to make this woman shut the
[__] up. That's crazy. We thought we were still in
the middle of discussions when without warning, the mediator,
who's a retired judge, ourselves as lawyers, without any prior
warning, still thinking that we were close to a final agreement.
The plaintiff and her lawyer from Houston filed a case in Texas
publicly accusing my client of lies and willful harmful lies
by using the word when it was she knows 100% knows uh and the
evidence uh will show that she knew that this was entirely consensual.
So we were uh of the belief on our side that we had an agreement.
Okay, I need this to go faster. Can we speed this guy up? We
can any warning. Not even the mediator who is a retired judge
was given a warning out of courtesy. This case was filed and
the public charges went throughout. Shannon Sharp may not even
have $59 million. He played back in the day when tight ends made
$45 million a year. Yeah. If you think Shannon Sharp has earned
the lion share of his money through playing football, you're
insane. You're out of your mind. No. Shannon Sharp has made basically
all of the money he'd have now from broadcasting. I doubt he
made a lot of money. I doubt he made insane money while he played
football. The media 22 million in the NFL. Yeah, he's made way
more outside of the NFL as a broadcaster. He is like one of the
most beloved personalities in all of sports talk radio basically
before we even knew that the discussions were over and the case
had been filed. Mr. Davis, last Friday, Front Office Sports reported
Mr. Sharp was in line for a 100 million deal for his podcast.
On Sunday, the lawsuit was filed. Is there a timing issue here?
You made the issue here. Okay, we don't need to hear much more
from the lawyer. They offered something to tens of millions.
Okay, strap yourself. Oh, are we going to watch these guys talk
through this real quick? Give me two seconds. I'm actually uh
I'm in the middle of like I'm getting a drink. I'm making some
food really quickly. I only have to warm stuff up. I have leftovers.
So, give me two seconds in because we're about to tell you something
that's a a woman. It looks like a former girlfriend who says
that he assaulted
Okay, this is this is going to get juicy. has got a lot of the
audio in it. We're going to go from this and then I think we're
going to turn on the act video. Okay, so
strap in saying uh denying it all together saying this is a shakeddown.
Uh she's just trying to get money out of me and he puts a lot
of blame on her attorney Tony Busby as well. This is the Tony
Busby as in the Diddy lawsuits. Correct. Uh Tony Busby is representing
the Jane Doe. She's filed as Jane Doe. Uh, but this morning Tony
Busby dropped an audio recording that he says his client made
as a phone conversation between herself and Shannon and they
get into an argument and you will hear what Shannon said to her.
Um, and then we'll get into Shannon's response to this. I don't
know. Anything I say, you're just going to like get mad at and
you're just going to hang up on me. So, I feel like I'm not going
to hang up on you. really what it is. What? What does that even
mean? Nothing, Gabby. You want to be a for me now. So, I don't
want to be. Don't manipulate me. Oh, Lord. Have mercy. If you
said that one, oh, Lord have mercy. I love his little southern
witicisms. That's what made him big. Okay. That's why we all
love Shannon. He's just like he's a good old boy. All right.
Wait, that's not racist, right? Good old boy. I don't think so.
I'm going choke out of you when I see you. Thank you. Okay. Oh,
I don't want to be choked. Yes, you do.
Oh my god. Uh, is that like gigach? I can't even tell. That seems
kind of That seems a little crazy. Shannon, what are you doing?
Ank, what are you doing?
I don't think you have a choice in the matter. Oh, yeah. Um,
like to me. So, yeah, that seems like way more likely to be kink
that they're in that situation. Like if you're fighting, you're
saying you're to choke somebody. It's that's not like how you
talk, right? Am I crazy? So, uh, the pull up the pic. Wait, the
meme or what? Obviously bleeped out. Just to be clear, I'm going
to choke the out of you the next time I see you. Um, now what's
interesting is the end of that conversation where he says,
uh, you don't have a choice in a matter. Sim, thank you for the
primer. One of the things that that Shannon said in response
to this when the lawsuit was filed is that they had a relationship
where there was a lot of role playing. So this was a consensual
relationship for over several months. Role playing you say? Role
playing you say where they did roleplaying. Uh there was rough
scenes. Uh, and he admitted to this and his lawyer released what
he says are text messages from this woman sent to Shannon where
she said things like, "But we should say this is going to be
really graphic, folks." Yes. Uh, I want you to put a dog collar
around my neck and choke me with it while you're blanking me.
And by the way, and I should say disgusting. Who would say things
like this? This is absolutely abhorrent. Could you imagine having
these kinds of DMs? My god. Absolutely disgusting. That the choking
aligns with what he says was going on, which is what you just
described, right? Uh I know you missed this big I know you miss
this big juicy ass. 25K for each cheek. Now, this is just baffling
to me. 25K for each cheek. That's a little wild. That's brh white
women out out here. I apparently that whole thing with the college
players. Okay, that's only a college age white woman thing. If
you're trying to date like Shannon Sharp, it's 25K per cheek.
Are you not going to read some of these? No, you you you're the
reader. I know you missed this big juicy blank 25K for each.
It's a white woman. How big could the ass possibly be? This is
like This is more expensive than Wagu, dude. It's nice. It's
chic. Uh you better crave it cuz you're going to be stuck with
it for life after you put a big black baby. So, what what they're
saying with the Sorry, I was going to get my food out of the
microwave that I warmed up. What did I just hear as I walked
away from my screen? What the? You better crave it because you're
going to be stuck with it for life after you put a big black
baby. Dude, why is everybody Why is race Why is like race play
everybody's thing? Why are so many people into this? It's crazy.
Why is she thinking about this so much? Because you're going
to be stuck with it for life after you put a big black baby.
So, what it's crazy a big black baby at me. I
what they're saying with these texts is that it aligns with the
nature of our the nature of the relationship which they're talking
about. So um Shannon this morning after Tony Busby released that
audio u recording Shannon decided he wanted to respond. Now here's
he actually recorded a video. He's not responding to the audio
recording itself. He's responding to the overall lawsuit and
says, "I don't think we need any more of this." Listen, I don't
think we need any more of this. I think what we need is possibly
to get to act. Okay, so she claimed Okay, hold on. Let's read
a little bit more on this. Davis literally later added that it
was a big surprise to us when he when suddenly this case was
filed without any advanced warning. Okay. Do through her famed
lawyer Tony Busby filed the lawsuit filed the lawsuit on Sunday
in Nevada. She claimed in it that the ex she met the ex Denver
Broncos player at a gym in Los Angeles. We saw this. So according
to her suit in late 2024 she tried to break things off with him.
He her she said he again assaulted her in January of 2025. So
apparently they got in a fight over funny enough when had the
IG live incident this girl thought they were monogamous. So that
she was pissed. Okay. And apparently when she was pissed I it
seems like the accusation is he came over and he wasn't listening
to her saying no I don't want to be around you and he had with
her possibly in line with like the fetish play they had set up
before but she said she was not not consenting to this. Okay.
Not not consenting at all. Okay. Let's continue on. We don't
need any of these videos. Called it a shakeddown cuz ACT A gets
into something. I I don't even know where the ACT doc is. Academics
has a dock here that like goes crazy. It's got so many details
in it. A went lawsuit and text thread with his assault accuser.
Shen requested his ass getting ate. This guy wants this guy wants
a salad toss. That's Listen, he was beating he was he was beating
the gay allegations and now I don't know. I don't know, man.
I don't know. Is to make him look like a super predator. He's
trying to say I'll expose that I'm I'm a freaky ass, but I'm
going expose that if every freaky ass hunk. Freaky ass hunk.
You got to keep it locked down, Unk.
I'm not I think um you got to be careful with this, right? This
is I think Shannon knew. Everybody knows, okay, you send you
send texts like this, they'll be used against you one day. You
you shouldn't do it. I understand in the moment. Listen, I've
been in the throws of like a an emotional moment, okay? And it's
like, I'm going to text some crazy. And then you realize that
that person has that crazy in their inbox for the rest of their
life is up. This predator being a freaky ass, not a crime. A
predator and a is right. So, here we go, chat. Little trigger
warning for everybody who's watching. Um, you know, I know again
I don't know if today was probably the best day to go live on
TikTok, but please, and also drill, whenever you upload this,
I need you to hear this. Make sure we get our blurring or whatever
going. I can't blur live because we have his full text messages.
Okay, wait, we're on Twitch. Wait, Twitch. This should be fine
on Twitch, right? This is investigative journalism, guys. Do
not forget to open Twitch, by the way. Twitch.tv/jc with an underscore.
Okay, twitch.tv/jk. TV/JSOK. Jst with an underscore. Here, I'll
put it in the chat for you guys. Twitch.tv/jstk with an underscore.
Go open up both streams. You need both streams open. I need you
in both. Okay. Okay. Thank you. So, we got the indict, not indictment.
Uh, we have the civil complaint here and should be here. This
is a civil complaint. We read this last night. I'm not going
to read it again. Just to give you two important details before
we get into anything. Is that the woman claims that she met him
in 2023.
She claims that after September 2024 when he was exposed on Instagram
live having with some woman named Michelle. That's the thing.
Um yes, he was exposed on Instagram live having with a different
woman. Not this woman, a different woman. And that is what led
to things getting crazy. Or when now hold on. Is this the same
complaint I've got? I've got one complaint here. Let me see if
No, cuz I don't have pictures in my complaint. Axe got pictures
in his complaint. I ain't got no pictures in my Well, there are
pictures here a little bit. Okay. All right. All right. All right.
He was exposed on Instagram live having with some woman named
Michelle. They started beefing. They fell out and apparently
he invited her over or what she said forced her to come over
and then he pushed up on her and he pushed up on her in a non-consensual
way and he this is the allegation. M what was mentioned in the
indictment is a thing about and by the way Shannon Sharp puts
that out too where she says no means no. Shannon is trying to
say no no she wasn't saying no means no that I shouldn't her.
She wanted me to use a condom which still is a very gray area.
So you're going to see all this but Shannon
uh what? Excuse me. Hold on. I thought I thought she wanted the
baby gravy. I thought she wanted a big black baby inside of her.
Is it was this false advertising? Was she talking a game? She
couldn't listen. She was talking a game. Her mouth was cashing
checks that her uh that her couldn't cash. Okay. She didn't want
it raw. She didn't want it raw. And she might have said that'sed
up. Okay. Not that he's allowed to do whatever he wants, but
it's up to say you want the baby gravy and then you don't want
the baby. That's crazy. And he's putting everything out for the
public. Okay. Um, also he announced that he's suing her for defamation
even though she hasn't spoke herself, but you know, I guess she's
speaking through a lawyer. We haven't seen a lawsuit from him
yet. Okay. So, uh, apparently he gets caught on Instagram live,
which by the way, you know, remember people said that Shannon,
even I said I said, nah, that went live on purpose to show he
wasn't gay. If that was the case, this being the byproduct, horrible
decision because you [__] with your other, right?
Because clearly he wasing other girls. This one girl got mad.
She's claiming that he invited her over to try to like get to
some type of place of whatever. He's he's claiming that he raped
her and then somehow she kept talking to him and he raped her
again a couple months later. That's kind of odd, but whatever.
So that's that's what the
alg I guess it's odd. It's like realistically if they had some
kind of like they had some kind of BDSM relationship. Let's say
let's say that's the kind of relationship they had, right? this
BDSM relationship
and he he this this happened. It might be confusing for the girl
about like oh well he kind of thought he would have had consent
or something like it could be it could get confusing. She might
not have like broken it off immediately because what's a after
you've done simulator like a hundred times. What's a little No,
not really. Not really. I I'm just playing devil's advocate.
But that might have been how she looked at it. Okay. A little
bit are that he ripped her twice and here was some messages they
put in. Oh, do we get some Hassan's bad? Han is bad. Hold on.
Assan is bad. Assan is bad. Assan is bad. Okay, so this is what
the lawyer What is happening with this? Do we not Do I need to
go find a Do we have a website or something that's got all these
texts? Okay, my bad. I didn't get a chance to find this. So,
this is the complaint.
And he's going to read some of them to us. Wait. Jesus. Okay.
No. No. He's trying to blur. What the [__] He's doing
a bad job of blurring. This isn't that. Oh my. He's doing a horrible
job of blurring. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. There's lots
of information here. Oh, they didn't put it in the exhibit. All right,
never mind. So, so, so we have Shannon Sharp's text messages.
Here they are. So, this is supposedly every text that Shannon
ever sent her. Shannon leaked this because they put excerpts
in there and it didn't really help, right? It made it only used
the worst text message he sent. So, let let's go to this and
um again, you know, this is where they're saying he doxed her
because her number is kind of listed. Please don't. The number's
already changed, too, so you won't whatever. Anyway, so the green
is going to be Hold on. I need to see these texts. Where are
these texts? Dude, I'm getting bounced around a thousand different
articles with these texts. Just give me the document with the
texts. There's a million articles that are like that are like
here are the texts. You release the text. Where do you release
them? Is this it? Maybe this is it. Hold on. Let me take a look.
Okay. Uh well, this is some of them, but this isn't all of them.
Hold on. Let me check it out. Make this get bigger. Get bigger.
Get bigger. From Gabby to Shannon. But I cried when you left
because I begged you to put a condom on and not put it in my
ass and you didn't listen. I don't care what our history is.
No means no. Shannon, I don't know how to process this. Uh, can
I call you later? Oh, no. Listen, I know you're accusing me of
but I'm a little busy right now. Um, stealth stealth anal BBC
is not can't possibly be a pleasant experience. Okay. I I'm just
saying what we all know to be true. No. Yes. Yes. I feel like
we can all see that this is must be true. This is TeamZ Sports.
Team Z Sports. Shannon Sharp texts. Let's see if I can get an
article. Newly released text messages. Ah, yeah. Okay. Here's
a TMZ article with these. Okay. So, there's that one. And then
there's from from a year before. Okay. From sorry, a half a year
before, six months before. She says, "I want to be abused, daddy."
Okay. I want to be abused, daddy. Is what she said. Not me. I
would never say that. That's weird. That's weird. How do you
stealth with that? Yeah, it's probably not very stealth, is it?
Uh, so hold on. Let's Let's actually read through some of these.
Shannon Sharp's accuser confronted him over alleged January 25
ah over the alleged January 2020 assault with a new a newly released
text message showing the woman told him no means no Shannon.
The combo took place on the evening of January 2nd, the day Jane
Doe alleged in the lawsuit that Shannon Sharp her. Who read these
ones? Do tell Sharp blah blah blah blah blah. Okay. The texts
were released to Teams Sports along with hundreds of others on
Tuesday afternoon. Most of the messages show what appears to
be a kinky consensual relationship between the two. I want to
be abused, daddy. I want like some hardcore BDSM action, though.
Oh god. Are we just going to take we're going to take all of
her texts and just put them out here and say, well, she probably
wanted it. Is that what we're going to do? Is that is that our
our game plan here? This was freaky as that means she wanted
in the ass with no condom, with no preparation. That's that's
what that means, guys. Apparently, in one which Do sent to Sharp
in June 24, she want to be daddy. Another sent in July 2024,
she writes, "I want you to tie me up like this and abuse me,
daddy." In a third, dated January 31st, 2024, she requests some
hardcore BDSM action from the Pro Football Hall of Famer. What
the is happening here? I want you to tie me up like this and
abuse me, daddy. And she sends a picture. Wow. Wow. I wish Kelly
was here to read some of these. This would be very funny if Kelly
was here. Damn. Okay. All of these. All of these are like somewhere.
Who has all of them? If you can find all of them for me, I'll
love you forever. I need all of them. Please. This is why safety
words are a thing. True. But those like those texts still look
weird and bad and I'm not totally sure. So from Shannon. And
by the way, I would imagine so this would be Shannon's number,
but I Shannon's number probably already changed, too. So this
is how this all starts. Shannon says, "Called you back." Looked
like he was trying to call her. This is when they first met,
right? This is, by the way, the date is here.
9:30, which is September 30th, um, 2023. Okay, perfect. So this
is her, right? She says, "What's up? Watching you back feel like
with you." Okay, this is like 2 weeks after they meet cuz they
supposedly meet like in in September. We got to look at the date.
We're we're trying to analyze through like going to look. So,
we're trying to do the same thing they meet in um by the way,
I ain't going to lie, chat. This is why you can't really text
chicks, bro. If you're famous, if you're famous like me, I'm
like, I can't say you can't say nothing crazy. Yo, you can't
be like, "Yo, send me a picture of that [__] with
your legs wide open and you splitting it and rubbing the clit."
[__] when she get mad at you, [__] she
gonna have that [__] up on the I can't believe that's
like the that that statement from academics right there. Okay,
that was so vanilla that to me I'm like axe into some wild [__]
Okay. Acts into some devious deviant cuz that was like he just
said something like aggressively normal and it sound the way
he said it the way he said it it sounded like he was throwing
spice on it but he just said something like kind of aggressively
normal and that makes me think that like the actual thing he
would text to people is way different like crazy different on
the damn screen which y'all gonna see some of this. So all right
then she texts again and she says I want you. So this is, you
know, so this was the seventh. I don't know if this is every
text, but I guess he they're claiming these are the valuable
texts. Then two days later after they've been with each other
for like two weeks or three weeks cuz they met um in September,
now it's October October 2023. She um Yeah, I'm aware Sophia
that he got sued. Yeah, there's some probably some weird going
on in that one, too. I remember covering it. You're right. You're
right. You're right. I want you to put a come to very interesting
conclusions sometimes. I'm sorry, but he was like, I can't text
some crazy like you should open your legs and play with your
in your [__] Like that's what he said. Okay, that's
what he said. It was not crazy. It was like basically as benign
as possible. And that makes me think that in his head that wasn't
his crazy talk. That was him being like, I'm going to say something
in a crazy voice. But I can't actually tap into that part of
my mind that would send that text because if I do that, I'm gonna
say some insane [__] That's how I heard. That's what
I see. Choke me with it. Why you [__] me? You know
what Shannon Sharp says? He loved the message, so he hit the
heart button on the message. Ank wants to do the dog color thing.
Okay. Ank thinks dog color thing sounds good. Oh my god. Oh my
god. Let's go. Perfect. Then he continues. He says two minutes.
Which by the way, these random messages make it feel like that's
all the messages that they have between them because this not
an important message. So I don't I don't know if Shannon's team
gave all the messages or only important messages. Then Shannon
says, "Can I call you later?" Look like she's calling him, right?
And he's not answering. Then she sends an attachment. She says,
"When I'm 152 pounds, but you can't touch me because you cheated
on me on Instagram live." Now this
Okay, this is interesting because again, this is why I say it's
not all messages cuz we jump a year. It went from
2023, October 2023 to now December. What does that mean? What
do you mean? What does that mean? That means that she's pissed
that she that he was Michelle or whoever the 24. Okay, so clearly
they're like random messages probably like, "Oh, what you want
to eat?" Oh, I'm ordering something on blah blah blah. What?
like, oh, so those messages got to be deleted. It's no way they
only texted. They have a lapse in a year where there's no messages,
right? So, it's not all the messages, but supposedly these are
the relevant messages, right? Okay, cool. Then, all right, so
she says, so, so basically, remember in 2024 in
September, Shannon Sharp has with some random woman on Instagram
live. She's mad at Shannon Sharp, okay? Because she feels embarrassed,
okay? So, you know, I guess she's sending him a picture. This
is a picture right here. I won't show the picture fully, but
she says, "This is when I'm 152 lbs." Which, by the way, how
tall is she? If she 152 lbs. So, but you hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. He scrolls by it really quickly, but we can stop. That's
uh her just taking like a mirror selfie and pro. It looks like
that could be gym wear. Show the picture fully, but she says,
"This is when I'm 152bs." By the way, how tall is she? This weirdo
spamming some crazy So, but you can't touch me cuz you cheat
on me on Instagram live with Michelle. Then she says, "I'm going
to be 180." Wait, how tall is this girl? No mods in the in the
kit chat right now, eh? No mods. I got to I got to take care
of that myself. Mods. Hello. Yo, a chick being 180 to me is crazy.
What the How tall is she? She got to be Shannon. How tall is
she? Kickhat. Kick. Kick. Let's look at some Wait, 180. She said
15 when I'm 152 pounds. Which, by the way, how tall is she? If
she 152 pounds, what? So, but you can't touch me because you
cheat on me on Instagram live with Michelle. Then she says, "I'm
going to be 180." Wait, how tall is this girl? Be 180 soon. Yo,
a chick being 180 to me is crazy. What the 180 would be nuts?
180 would be nuts.
How tall is she? She got to be Shannon. How tall is Shannon?
Let's Let's look at some chat. How tall is Shannon? Now, I like
petite women. Just me personally, chat. I can't a chick 180.
I'm like, what we going to do? Box like what the Okay. Um 230.
Uh whatever. Okay, cool. I got to see how it looks on her, but
I mean she don't look big at all. How tall is Damn. What is a
doing? She a What are you?
Ah, I guess it's [__] time. I think this is allowed
by most standards for toos. But I guess it's [__]
time. Yes. Snowbody demon. Snowbody demon investigations with
DJ Academics. Kind of looks like 130 135. If she said she was
about to She don't look 180 right here. That's crazy. Yeah, she
said she'll get to 180. Not that she is 180. What the Tom 10?
We doing Tom 10 now. She looks 180. Ain't no way. It's no way
I look at this chick and say she's 180 lbs. Chat, what y'all
think? Huh?
What y'all think? What y'all think? Hold on. Oh, she looks that
Well, maybe I don't know. Wait. I I don't know what 180 looks
like on a woman. I don't know. Now you say she looks like 150.
I don't even get that. Or maybe I just think women are lighter
than they are. All right, whatever. Okay, because just act pondering.
Act's like, damn, she she didn't look a shade over 140. She does
look good here. All right, cool. Fine. What are we doing? What
are we doing, A? Um, all right, cool. So, she said he's just
showing the full numbers over here, too. Like, the blurring is
literally doing nothing. He could have just shown the document.
He's just showing the full numbers anyway. Why is it blurred
over here? And he's showing the full numbers on the left side.
She might be 180 soon. He says this is 12. It looked like he
must have [__] her, right? So remember, she sent
this then. She sent this then. Um, she says, "I'm going to be
180 soon and you're still not going to be able to touch me. I
bet you regret your actions right about now." Now, here's my
problem with like even her side. If he someone on Instagram live
in September and you're mad and you haven't him and now y'all
are texting in December, you know he's another woman, right?
Like it's no way Shannon Sharp because you cut off the supply
in September is not somebody by December, right? But whatever.
So Shannon texts her back. Freaky ass Shannon. I'll be that young.
Okay, I ain't going to lie. Shannon do text like a old man. be
that is a that is boomers. I'mma be kidnapped. I'mma be kidnapped.
All right, cool. Then she texts. She says, "Absolutely not. When
you give me a formal apology for cheating on me on Instagram
live and multiple other times, then we can talk about it." What
does a formal apology look like? What? Hold on. Isn't every Shannon
Sharp apology a formal apology? This guy. How is this not a formal
outfit? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Is this going to pop up or not?
Hey, go away. Go away. Yeah, listen. This guy is always in formal
wear. Okay. This guy's always wearing something formal. This
guy's very fashion-minded. What is a formal? Like, does she want
a drafted letter? I Now, it's almost like she's like acting like
they're in a like a relationship, right? But like she's like
trying to stand on business, right? Now, she then says formal
apology. Yo, Shannon got to be looking at his phone like all
caps, [__] All caps. formal apology
20. You crazy hell. All right. Then she sent I don't know what
this attachment is, but it's something. I don't even want to
click. Can I click it? Someone get me this document. How has
nobody been able to find this document yet? Can somebody look
for this document? We should be able to find it. And then I should
be able to look at it. I think we we should be able to. I believe.
So, why are we watching DJ DJ academics like paw through this?
We could just get the document ourselves. I'mma put this right
here. here. Let me see if if I click on it, it goes anywhere.
My bad, Shannon. Oh, yeah. It doesn't go anywhere. Okay, cool.
Then she says, "I'm not answering your calls. Sorry, Shannon."
So, it look like Shannon is blowing up her phone, right? She
might got that wet wet. I ain't going to cap, right? Got to like
you like, man, I can't lose this young, man. Like, damn. Shannon
blowing up her phone. She not answering. She said, "I'm not answering
your calls until you say sorry, Shannon." Here what Shannon says.
I've said sorry, Gabby.
Right, Gabby. Then she says, "All you say is I'm sorry, but you
never say what you're sorry for. How are you gonna make it
right?" She means money. Then she also said, "I also Yeah, she
might got that wet wet is like a weird way to talk about somebody
claiming that she was anally with a BBC." Stealth stealththed
anally with a BBC. Okay, that must have been a painful experience.
So I would appreciate if you could do that because you really
hurt me. So this is that like it looks like the day after Christmas
which by the way everybody know right around holiday time if
like you got to hit up your ex and all all these [__]
cuz like now you think like damn I I spent last holiday with
you type [__] That's kind of what's happening. So
he's blown up. What? That's like wait what actress gave us another
window into his mind. He just gets like lonely around the holidays.
He wants to hit up all the other women he's like spent other
holidays with. I didn't expect that. That sounded like a player
move. That's not a player move. Players do that because they
don't want their side pieces to get mad at them for not checking
in. Right? That would be the player mindset would be I check
in with these people so that they don't freak the out that I'm
not checking in with them on the holidays. Right? But uh but
academics is like, "No, I think about how like I uh I miss spending
Christmas or like Valentine's Day with this woman, so I'm I check
in on them then." It's like that's that's kind of adorable actually.
Oh my god. They're kind of going back and forth, but she won't
talk to him on the phone. She's just texting. It says, "So, I
would appreciate if you do that because you hurt me and I've
been having a hard time with it." So, she's saying she's affected
by it. Then, I guess she keeps he keeps calling. She says, "What
did I tell you, Shannon?" And then she says, "I told you to apologize
then we could talk." Then she says, "The fact that um the fact
that you Dude, DJ Academic's reading stream goes hard. Can't
do the simple thing is proven that you don't care about me. I
probably don't read better. It's just fun watching somebody else
read." And like it's Listen, just reading in front of an audience
not always the easiest thing. All right. Not as easy as you would
think. It should be very easy. It's not always as easy as you
would think, though. Sometimes it's uh sometimes it's not that
it's not that. Then she says, "I'm winning for my quite what
you think." Okay. Now, here here's the interesting part about
all this chat. This seems like a woman who probably was just
in love that is upset that her partner cheated and she wants
an apology and wants it to be sincere and wants him to show that
he gives a about her and loves her. This is where it goes left
and this is why I think Shannon put out all these messages cuz
it shows it showcases her true
nature. I need to see what's going to be said here. I don't trust
I don't trust a in the same way when he says it shows her true
nature. I'm like what does true nature mean to act?
Oh, okay. Do I care about any of these numbers being here? This
is like a published document. I don't know if I have to care.
Like I unfortunately there are numbers here. I just don't know.
Like once these are published, do we care? Is this a problem
if we show this? I feel like it's not like these are a part of
like legal documents
and I think I I think I'm just going to show it. I think A went
I think A went hard and A's fine. So yeah, I'm just I'm going to
just pull it up. [__] it. Cuz act act just for the
YouTube video blurred. But I don't know if you I don't know if
you have to worry about it that much to be honest. It's on a
website called Baller Alert. It is. All you say is I'm sorry,
but you never say what you're sorry for or how you're going to
make it right. Oh yeah. What did I tell you, Shannon? I told
you to apologize and then we can talk. This is Boxing Day. December
26th. Are all of these over Christmas? These are all in December
26th. I'm not answering your calls, Shannon. It's all Dude, Shannon's
got a family. Shannon's got kids. and he's messaging his 20-year-old
sidepiece. Okay. Well, one of many on the day after Christmas.
Isn't that sad? Feel like that's sad. Shouldn't you be like hanging
out with your family and all happy and stuff? O, I told you you
can apologize then we can talk. Fact is you don't do this simple
thing is uh the fact that you can't do this simple thing. Sorry.
Is proving to me that you don't care about me. I'm waiting for
my apology is the next day. I don't understand why it's so hard
for you to say sorry for what you did. Gabby, I'm not going through
this again. I've already apologized. Stop playing
games. Ank is like, "You know what? You, Gabby, you you you I'm
not I'm not playing these games, Gabby. Oh, god." Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. This is bad. This is bad, actually. Wait. Oh,
no. A, it's not. A, what are you doing? No.
No. Gabby, I'm not going through this again. I've already apologized.
Stop playing childish games. on the 27th of December, 4 days
later on New Year's. Happy New Year, Gabby. Can't wait to see
what 2025 has in store for us. He's fishing. He's fishing in
2025. He's fishing. Chat's covering some of the text. Uh-oh.
Hold on. We'll have to fix this. We'll have to move this over
here. Boom. There it is. There it is. Dude, he he's fishing.
He Give 50k and I'll let you come over to the house. What? Wait.
50k in what direction? Oh, rough. Carly Justice. Oh, that's the
only fans handle. She is going to get a lot of business, dude.
This is actually Is that like the only This is like all upside
for her. Even if she loses the case, she just threw out her Only
Fans handle. Okay, she's in the She's in the red or sorry, she's
in the black now. Okay, in more way than one, but she's in the
black financially. Okay, financially she's in the black. She
gonna get so many subs. Yeah. Hold on. Maybe this is where 25K
per cheek came from. 50K. I want both cheeks, baby. I want both
cheeks, you know. I want both cheeks. What is the sound of one
cheek clapping? It's not really anything. I need both. I make
myself laugh sometimes. Okay. Don't have cash apps. Okay. It's
PayPal. You have PayPal. Then what do you have? 10K cash. Oh,
he's negotiating. He said 50k. He bait and switched. He baited
and switched. Now it's 10k cash. Well, I don't have 50. Ah, you
know, 50k, she replies. He's like, 10k cash. Okay, 5k per cheek.
That's a that's a big discount. Okay, that's a 80% off discount.
5k per cheek. Send me a pick or ft me with it. FaceTime me with
it. Oh, what's taking you so long? You either don't have the
cash to show me right now or you're with Michelle. Which one
is it,
Shannon? Oh. Oh, this is a crazy picture right here. I can't
really go any closer into that. I can see that it doesn't violate
toss. Okay, I can see that it doesn't violate toss, but the pick
is pretty insane if you could see from just this tiny little
bit of pixels. Just this tiny little bit of pixels. That's pretty
crazy. Oh [__] that was actually going to go somewhere.
Jesus Christ. Okay. Okay, I clicked on it and it was like, oh,
it was actually Okay, now I have to go all the way back down
to where we were January 1st. Right there. Okay, that's where
we were. Okay, I know you missed this big juicy ass. 25K for
each cheek. Okay, this is 25K for each cheek. That was after
Dr. Umar isn't a real doctor. Yeah, but he's got the medicine.
Okay, Dr. Umar's got the medicine for this situation. All right,
for all young black men out there who are really struggling to
make it out out in the the world, the wide world, the wide wild
world, Dr. Umar's got some advice for you. Okay, he's got some
advice. Snow bunnies ain't winning, my brother. It's black queens
forever. Snow bunnies never. Snow bunnies ain't winning, my brother.
It's black queens forever. Snow bunnies never. Snow bunnies ain't
winning, my brother. It's black queens forever. It's black queens
forever. Snow bunnies never. Black queens forever. Snow bunnies
never. Okay. Okay. See, if you got a snow bunny, that makes you
a snow dummy. If you got a snow bunny, That makes you a snow
dummy. If you got a snow bunny, that makes you a snow dummy.
I love that this guy repeats everything three times. It really
makes it stick in my head. Okay. If you got a snow bunny, then
you a snow dummy. I'll never forget it. If you got a snow bunny,
that makes you a Wait, Dr. Umar gave a take on this. I'm getting
text messages from all over the house. Oh no, he got a Dr. prove
our reaction. No Shann universe telling me that Shannon's not
Shannon is not getting invited back to the cookout. Well, I actually
lied. Shannon is okay. One of the moves
he can't be uninvited. He's literally the life of the party.
But if he could be, this would be what would do it. Messages
from all over the African universe telling me that Shannon Sharp
was accused of the unspeakable. The Afric Oh my one of the moves
was I'm getting text messages from all over the African universe
telling the African universe. Is this a multiverse? Is there
an African multiverse that I'm unaware of? That Shannon Sharp
was accused of the unspeakable. I'm going to stand with Uncle
Shay on one condition. Uncle Shay, no more snow bunnies after
this scandal. If you cannot promise me that you will never seek
the company of another snow bunny, I cannot stand with you. I'm
standing with you, I think it's a scam. Yes, he's a lifetime
snow bunny hopper. But that's my brother. Shannon is so powerful
in his fame, in his magnetic personality that even Dr. Umar is
like, I will forgive you for your perpetual snow bunny hopping.
Okay, you you got a pair of snowshoes. You go. You go playing
in the snow all the time, but I'll let it go, brother. Because
you, you uncle Shay. Okay. You Shay, I can't let you go, brother.
I can't let you go. Okay. All right, Zezy. She's kind of a butterface.
Let's not talk about the woman's looks. It's 25K per cheek. Then,
it's not the cheeks on her face. Okay, that wasn't what it was.
25K per. Hold on. I stole this from Stylo in Chloic's Discord.
He had another Dr. Umar clip. Will this load? Please. Please
load. Hello. Hello. My streamable is dying. I should be able
to find it in any case, but might have to might have to grab
it again. Hold on. Do we have to grab it again? I might have
to grab it again. Where are we? Where are we? I'll find it. Don't
worry. I'll find I'll find I'll find it. Dr. Umar Johnson. Dr.
Umar Johnson. Let's go right here. Right now. Your wife is white.
So, we going to stop the black talk right there.
That's his normal opinion. How the did he go from that to Shannon
Sharp? Okay, I get it. You're a perpetual snowbody hopper, but
uh we'll talk. Okay, he's on Shay Shay. That should give you
a good idea of how powerful Shannon Sharp is. All right, best
Umar clip ever. Best Dr. Umar clip ever. But I want to be clear,
and I know some of us love our children, but some of our children
are so far gone that we going to have to put some of them to
sleep in order to take back the neighborhood.
Some of y'all don't want to hear that cuz you don't live in reality.
But I'm telling you as a psychologist, I'm not going to be able
to psychize all them on the corner. Some of them going to sleep.
Sorry. Holy [__] Dr. Umar disavow. Completely disavowed.
That was crazy. That was nuts. Quean live. Thank you for the
71 viewers. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Oh my god. Oh my
god. So then Gabby's messaging more 25k per cheek. She then sends
a picture of her cats. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
hold on. She sent this. I know you miss his big juicy ass. 25k
per cheek. Ank was trying to work her Ank didn't even have 10k
in cash. Okay, he didn't even have the 10k that he said. He was
not given that 10k. It's two months later where she messages
him. There's two cats and this is only uh this is only like a
month and a half ago. This is March 5th. Oh, sorry. This is March
5th, 2023. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, the
the texts are out of order. This is 2025. This is March 3rd,
2023. So, this is way earlier. So, she sent a picture of cats
to somebody. He says, "Hi," or she says, "Hi, says Ank loved
an image." That's me hugging you and you not hugging me back
again. March 2023. Uh, tie me up like this and me. And it's a
picture of like a BDSM situation. person is tied up like a Thanksgiving
turkey. Okay, kind of interesting, kind of cool, but this is
basic white woman talk. They're like, "Yeah, tie me up like this."
And then you get halfway through tying a knot and they're like,
"Ah, this is kind of boring. I Let's just watch The Office."
I bottle this rope. I bottle the Are you serious right now? I
went out of my way. 50 Shades of Shay. 50 Shades of Shay Shay.
If I knew how to, I would. Okay, that's that's real. I'm suddenly
Dude, this is why Ank wins all the time. That's so real. If I
listen, I'm not against it. It's just like it seems like a complicated
talent to learn, like a skill. I don't really have the time.
I've got like other avenues, other interests. I don't It seems
complicated. Okay. I don't sail. What do you want me to say?
It's okay. I have handcuffs. We can stick to those for now. All
right. She's improvising. Classic C. Classic improvisation. Okay.
That actually looks like you. What? It's all on the same day.
Oh. Oh, the this actually looks like her. Okay. Okay. Okay. Uh,
who said it's not
me? Little playful flirting back and forth. Her are too big for
to be you. Oh, Ank is Ank is in the negging. Riz. Okay. Ank is
a neggger. He uses negative sentiment to with women. Okay. Ank
negs. Don't make it weird. Do not make it weird. Do not make
it weird. Do not make it weird. Do not make it weird. I clearly
am talking about him saying her are too big for it to be you.
He is using negging as a tactic to with her. Do not make it weird.
Okay. You can't even see my in that.
Lau. Oh, maybe it is her. Wait, maybe it is her. Hold on. Well,
I'll have to investigate later when I'm not on stream. I don't
want to I don't want to zoom into this. Okay, that'd be weird.
But whatever you say, Daddy. Whatever you say, daddy. She wants
something. She wants something. She wants something. It can be
if you want. If you want. Oh, you can't even see my in that.
It can be if you want. What? What? Ank is like old as I want
to be in that position right now. It's too late now. 3 minutes
later. What? Three? She answered within 3 minutes. Ank has tight
deadlines. What the? He's old. It's all out of order. It's not
out of order. You can see the timing on all of them. It's in
time order. It's too late now. 3 minutes later. Two minutes later.
I guess I'm just going to have to myself in the ass with my dildo
now. Okay,
she's stepping on the gas. That's very aggressive. Jesus Christ,
that's aggressive. That's a lot. That is a whole heck of a lot.
Uh, follow me back on IG, I guess. Uh, follow me back on IG.
I accidentally blocked you. Oh, yeah. Very accidental. Surely
accidental. She Oh, this is Unk's got the Unks got the power
in the relationship right now. Okay. She wants in with Ank and
she got mad because she said this which was hitting the gas and
he didn't say anything. Okay. He said nothing. He backed off
entirely and she's Oh, I accidentally blocked you. Whoops. Whoops.
Whoops. Whoops. No, she didn't like that. She said that and there
was no response. Okay, I'll translate why Ank is being like this.
He doesn't respect her Only Fans content. He only knew it was
her. He knew that it was her and that's not a unique lude but
some promo for her. OF that's why he's so dismissive.
Uh maybe I don't I've not gotten any sort of uh savvy out of
this that like for what you're saying. Good night. Thanks for
always answering my texts and calls. This is the next day. Okay.
Uh Gabby did something I don't even know this but with you instead.
Uh some picture of her in like some DMs or something. Okay. Okay.
Oh, can you actually click on these? Hold on. If I click on these,
where does it go? Page not found. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right.
Who is that? Oh, I have no idea. I just look at my DM sometimes
when I'm in the mood to be creeped out. That's Chocolate
SL. He calls himself Chocolate Daddy. Oh no. Freaky ass, dude.
Freaky ass. Okay. Wait, is this This is within This is eight
minutes later. I I just look at my This is like This is just
strange to me. That's chocolate daddy.
I'm the only one [__] that and getting his ass
ate. The ass eating allegations are here. We're here. That's
exactly right, daddy. O. Ah, gross. That just got my wet. Tie
me up and do bad things to me.
up, dude. It's like I feel like it's like he's got a bunch of
other women. That's what it seems like. Mhm. You still have my
handcuffs. I want like some hardcore BDSM action, though. It
was all in the same night. Feeling kind of freaky lately. And
he sent a picture of what I believe to be I will zoom out. But
what I believe to be, okay, based on based on my knowledge of
human anatomy and several other things, I believe he sent this
very blurred. Okay. It's very blurry. All right. But I believe
he may have sent a picture of somebody's vagina and possibly
with semen leaking out of them. Okay. Very disgusting. Very gross.
I just showed that to my friends at dinner. You're my daddy.
Disgusting. Disgusting. Disgusting. Disgusting. Okay. Little
late on the zoom out, bro. Okay. Uh guys, we are ending the Twitch
stream because I do not want to get timed out on Twitch. That
ended very quickly. Okay. We ended the Twitch stream. We get
rid of that VOD immediately. A video producer. We go ahead and
we clap that VOD. That VOD is
Bye-bye. Get it out of here. Get it out. That VOD is very gone.
Goodbye. Goodbye, Seenor. We do not like that. We do not like
that at all. That was [__] crazy. Uh we're over on
kick. If you are watching the kick stream, good luck. Uh yeah.
Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. We'll go over to kick cuz that
was uh that was pretty crazy. That was That was pretty nuts.
That Listen, it's very zoomed out on kick, okay? It's very zoomed
out. We're okay. We're okay. We're okay. We'll be okay. We'll
be okay. It already ended. Uh, I I can restart the Twitch stream,
too, guys. Let's restart this the Twitch stream. Let's see what
happens. We'll continue on with this. Okay, we'll restart it.
Retry.
Doover. VOD. Gone. Accident. Big accident. Big- time accident.
Okay, we're doing it over. We'll go over to Twitch again. We're
loaded up. I just showed that to my friends at dinner. The picture
of the vagina. You're my daddy. Only if you put that baby gravy
in me, then I can do whatever I want to me. What? I think then
you can do whatever you want to me, right? But it's a baby. It's
the baby gravy. Oh god, she wants the baby gravy. Okay. Only
if you put that baby gravy in me. God. Oh, wait. Hold on. Thanksgiving
is in is in November. That's why her mind's there, right? Thanksgiving
is in November for Americans. Only if you put that baby gravy
in me. She was just eating turkey earlier that day or something.
These two message a lot on the holidays. Only if you put that
baby gravy. She corrects. Only if you put that baby gravy in
me, then you can do whatever you want to me. Oh my god. Male
mail. Male. Male. Male. Male. Male. Male. That's the text that
we got returned. Male. Male. Male. That's the baby gravy symbol.
The universal baby gravy symbol. Male. Male. Male. Oh my god.
I literally ate so much food. I look like I'm pregnant with your
big black baby. She has a real obsession with these big black
babies. This is weird. This is actually starting to get odd.
Okay. Is she planning to start like a football team or something?
What is What the is she saying? Also, I love that I actually
called the Thanksgiving thing, even though I don't know when
American Thanksgiving is. Clearly, that's what she was doing,
right? She was eating food at Thanksgiving. She was thinking
about gravy. Now, if this were a guy sending these messages to
a woman, people would question why he was fetishizing that woman
so badly. I think we should do the same thing here. I think it's
very disgusting that she is fetish fetishizing his blackness
and the the large blackness of him and his offspring and his
baby gravy. Okay, it's it's it's weird. It's bizarre. Why is
it happening? Isn't she being paid? No, actually the text where
she was discussing payment are from before this. We went from
2025 where she said 25k per cheek which was in January of 2025.
This is November of 2023. I don't know why we had the out of
orderness there at the beginning. Very odd. Uh, if I still with
you around, my birthday my bday. If I still [__]
with you around, my bday is 24. In 24, you can take IUD out.
Oh, as in 2024, if we're still take the IUD out. Oh, boy. He
calls himself chocolate daddy. I think she got the okay. All
right. Loved if I still with you around my my bday in 24. You
You piece of [__] Lol. You're stuck with me for life.
You're not going anywhere, babe. Loved the message. You're stuck
with me for life. You're not going anywhere, babe. Oh, wow. You're
too addicted to me. Are you doing the show tonight? Yes. Yes,
I am. Uh, call me daddy. I miss you. This is in So, they went
from November to January of 2024. Now, we're into 2024. Okay,
bro. IUDs are so [__] bass. What the [__]
Only redeeming quality about my ex. For real. For real. Uh, what's
wrong with birth control? Is there something Is there some problem
with birth control I'm unaware of that? Like you don't like that,
but you like IUDs? That's crazy and strange, but okay. All right.
Why did you read that? What did I read? What? Uh, call me. I
miss you, daddy. Call you back. Uh, this was the next day. The
next day. Call you back. KK. There must be calls in here that
we're not getting, right? There are call logs in here that aren't
in the texts. I'm thinking that's what it is. I'm going to put
my tongue your [__] and then marry you. Okay, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Uh, we're not on H. How do I do
this? Hold on. Let me move my face over here so that I'm blocking
any per possible. We're blocking any possible leaks of sensitive
images. I don't know. She's wearing this is not to unfriendly.
This one is not toss unfriendly. We can go like this and go back.
So, she sends a picture of herself. This is so from the 12th.
I want to put my tongue in your [__] and then marry
you. Wow. On January 12th. And then a little bit later, two minutes
later, she sends the picture. What is Does Unk reply? No reply
from Ank. Uhoh. Got to move the face back again. Uh, move the
face back again. Block again. Is this one okay? This one is okay
as well. She sends another picture. Uh, there it is. You can
see it on screen now cuz I didn't do a good job of blurring.
Brooke, call me back. Brooke, call me back. That's an hour later.
Okay. And no message. Oh.
O, no message. And then 5 hours later, she sends a message again
with uh something. Shannon Sharpen something else. This is 2024
still. January of 2024. I can't wait to have a black
baby. 10, bro. Okay. So, I don't know if if if he's not calling
back or what, but she sent on the 13th. I can't wait to have
a black baby. We don't get text messages back from him. Did uncle
leaks the DMs? Uh, Uncle leaks the DMs. I think Uncle leaked
the DMs. So, you will have to remember that these are Unks leaks,
okay? And these might be the leaks that look worse for her. The
absolute worst. Okay. Fetishizing the race of your kids is pretty
gross. Well, I think it's more about fetishizing the race of
the person who's you to be fair. Like, I don't think I don't
think that she's like fetishizing that her kids would be black.
I think she's fetishizing the idea of getting knocked up by a
black guy. I don't think I I think like the idea that she's talking
about the kids, it's like not about the kids. That's not like
she's like, "Oh, the idea that like I'll have a black." It's
different. It's just different. It's not the same thing. I think
she's fetishizing the bag. Yeah, probably. That's most likely.
Okay. Uh, on the plane. On the plane. Stop talking. On the plane.
On the plane. On the plane. On the plane. On the plane. On the
plane. On the plane. 10 minutes later. On the plane. He's on
the plane twice. You know I do, daddy. And a big black baby,
dude. I think he gets it. I think he gets it. You want a big
black baby? Could you just say a black baby? Do you have to keep
saying a big black baby? H Yeah, they're going to have linebacker
tight end genetics. They might even be big enough to play O line.
It's going to be a huge black baby. They might They might be
They might be like Michael. Okay, they could start on the blind
side. They're going to be so big. Oh my god. Just a massive black
baby. What the are we doing? What is happening? And she a thick
girl, too. She's not really a thick girl, though. Like, if we
go back to A and his uh his what do you call it? His um his TomTent
here. Act Tom. She's not that big at all. That's not that big.
Okay. I'm just saying it's not She's not that big. See you tonight.
Male. Male. He just does the mail symbol again.
What I will say throughout these texts at the at the start is
not in he does not have hand in the relationship to use a Seinfeld
term. Okay? He does not have hand. He's not have the the control
of the relationship. But that was in 2025. At the very beginning,
he had all the control. He was totally in control. He was too
busy for her. She was like constantly trying to get his attention.
And then he loses that over time. Many such cases. Okay. Many
such cases. I told you. Please stop hanging up on me like that.
At least say bye. It's very disrespectful. Shannon, I want to
If I was 38, I would definitely impregnate you. I'm not giving
you that baby gravy. I'm too old. I'm too old to give up the
baby gravy now. Okay. I'm too old. If I was 38 or if you were
38. I mean, you could still impregnate me. Impregnate me. Age
is just a number. Me, Gabby. That's a kink for you. You and both
know you and I both know you don't want a baby. You're the one
who that has the breeding kink. I mean, I only want a baby if
it's from you. I think I'd be a good mom. I always wanted a black
baby. Okay, [__] Okay, this is her version of posting
a black square. Okay, she's like standing in solidarity. No,
you're not. That's that's weird. Okay, this is performative.
All right, you're not you're not sitting here as like a in solidarity
with the black community. You're here in solidarity with this
incredibly popular, incredibly rich black man looking for a part
of that money. Okay, that's more what I think at this point.
I don't I don't know if she wants if she always wanted a black
baby, but she did always want a black baby from somebody worth
a quarter of a billion dollars. Okay, that's to be fair, that's
probably most people. All right. All right. Call you back after
dinner. This going to August 2024. That's my daddy. I want you
to put a big black baby in me. Stop talking about the size of
the child. Please, for the love of God. For the love of God,
stop talking about the the largeness of the child of the infant.
Stop with this. I don't know what we're doing here. What are
we doing here? Screenshot that and send it to her. Like what
the Oh, I'd be sub to that if it's free. Oh
well, I'll let you I'll let you make it hang whenever you want,
Daddy. But only if you take me out and treat me good. Deal. I
crave your Gabby. That's my now. I crave your Gabby. That's my
cookie now. Oh my god. You better crave it cuz you're going to
be stuck with it for life after you put a big black baby in me.
No. This is enough. I've had enough. This is This woman cannot
keep fetishizing the size of this child. Okay, this is garbage.
This is actual garbage. What are we doing? What does this world
come to? Okay, I'm I'm already racist. Okay, why you got to do
this whole thing with the whole misogynation thing and then make
me feel worse? Okay, I was already a little bit racist. This
is like pushing me towards but not against black people, okay?
Against white women. I'm actually just becoming more racist against
white people. This ised up. White people want money at any cost.
At any cost. It's crazy. It's crazy. You better crave it. Oh,
yeah. Big black baby. Big black baby. She posted an Instagram
picture. It's something else. Uh, what is that? Is that like
an aquarium? That's like a water tank. That must be an aquarium.
Yes. Yes. Oh, this is March 2023 again. What? Oh god, now they
are out of order. March 2023. What the? This is like way earlier
than the other ones. Yes, me too. So glad we're on the same page.
I want to be abused, daddy. I want to be abused, daddy. I'm so
sick. I need church. I want to be abused, daddy. I'm so sick.
I need church. Those are aed up. That's a up onetwo punch. Okay,
that's nuts. I just want to be abused, daddy. I'm so sick. I
need church.
That's crazy though. That second line is devious. Okay, that's
devious. And he reacted or something. Sent a blank im a blank
text. So when are you going to be able to provide me with this
week? Or should I we wait until this weekend when you're not
working quote unquote? Oh, what's going on here? We're reading
texts of a interracial relationship where the woman fetishizes
black men and the black guy's just trying to get his wet. Okay.
And also happens. Is this about? Yeah, getting it in. Okay, Shay
Shay getting it in. And this woman is uh she's sending some wild
texts. All right. Now, this doesn't mean she wasn't, by the way,
as funny as this is. Listen, sounds like she is a breeding kink.
I've not heard her talk. Well, except the one time she talked
about yourself in the ass of the dildo. I've not heard her ask
for it in her ass. Okay. No protection in the ass. That's crazy.
Or should we wait? Okay. you. Yo, can you freeze your sperm and
then give it to me in like 5 to 10 years? And he replied, he
replied with just a male mail again. Why does he keep replying
with this? How does he have this? How does he just have this
unlock? Male male male. Every time she talks about his semen,
it's male male male. Baby gravy. Male, male, male. Put a big
black baby in me. Male, male, male. Why you want a big black
baby? He's trying to engage.
He's trying to engage back. Why? You want a big black baby? What?
Yo, you can Can you freeze your sperm, then give it to me in
five to 10 years? Why you want a big black baby? What is he talking
about? That's exactly why she wants the frozen sperm. Are you
serious? Yes, exactly. Yeah. Unk's reading comprehension. It's
not up there. Okay, it's not. Hey, JTock, did our relevant get
banned from kick? I don't know. I don't think so. Why would he
have been banned from kick? Is his page not loading? His page
loads for me. Got his fuds, got his [__] got everything.
No, he is not banned from kick. Why' you think he's banned from
kick? That's crazy. Hey, listen. Your wife is white, so we going
to stop the black talk right there. Sorry. Dr. Remar clip real
quick. Real quick, real quick. Real quick. Real quick. I'm trying
to have genetically gifted children, you know.
Jesus. She's starting a farm team. She's She's raising strong
stock. Okay. She's looking for the strongest stock she can get.
This is nuts. Why are you calling Shannon? Because everybody
calls Shannon Sharp Unk. Shannon calls himself Unk. His whole
fan base calls him Unk. That's what they call him. Just trying
to raise an offensive line. She's trying to create her own She's
trying to recreate the blind side. Okay. She got a She's got
a Oscar winning movie going on in her ovaries. Okay. She'll she'll
put somebody in every position. To be fair, if you're gonna try
to find, if you're gonna try to mine genetic freaks, genetic
freaks, Shannon Sharp is not the wrong place to start. If you
don't know, Shannon Sharp was not even the best football player
in his family. He made the Pro Football Hall of Fame. His brother
was a prolific wide receiver who got injured, lost his career
very early, but was still made the Hall of Fame. His brother
probably would have been one of the best wide receivers ever
if he hadn't gotten injured and up his whole career, right? So,
like those genetics are gold. This woman is not wrong. She's
done her research. There's There's white gold in them their balls.
Okay, there's white gold. Okay, I'm have trying to have genetically
gifted children. How old is this? Is from 2023. Okay, I need
them athletes. Stop. Stop saying this. Maybe she is fetishizing
the children. He's like, Shannon's money will tide me over until
I'm old enough to retire off of the money for my kids that he
God. Me selling art. Me selling art. Wow.
Crazy. Good night. I'm getting your name tattooed on me in like
an hour, by the way. Just thought I'd let you know. Yeah, this
girl. This girl's crazy. All right. She's crazy. Where's Kelly?
I don't know where Kelly is. I wanted Kelly to come do this,
but Kelly didn't want to be here. So, what can you do? What can
you do? Kelly wouldn't have wanted to read these. Kelly would
have been like, "I'm not reading that I want to be abused, daddy."
tweet. I'm not giving you that soundboard. Just I'm not giving
you that soundboard. I Why are my accents so bad? I just want
to do accents and I'm so bad at them. God, why is it so bad?
I just tried to do a British accent. It was not close. I could
probably do a British accent. I just did a weird voice. I don't
even know what I did there. Listen, I got to work on it, okay?
I got some internal some like selfwork to do. Oh, that was terrible.
I don't even know what that was. I just feel I'm I'm like right
there. I need I need I possibly am looking to end the stream
off of that. Okay, that was not great. That was not great at
all. That was like a 40s doctor on TV. Dude, that was up. Kind
of over the Shannon Sharp [__] Too bad. I'm having
fun. So, leave if you're over it. Okay. I'm getting your name
tattooed.
In the front of my cognac. In the font of my cognac. Yes, daddy
on my neck. What? In the font of my cognac. Yes, daddy on my
neck. This is 30. This is 49 minutes later. Yes, daddy on my
neck. In the font of my cognac. Yes, daddy on my neck. Aha. If
I can get it or I if I get it, can I maybe be your baby mama?
Oh, that's where the tattoo's going. Oh, yes. in front of my
cognac. So, she's talking about the tattoos still. You better
not be up to any sus with them Vegas hookers.
Okay. Ah, that was fun. That's all the text messages. So, we
got act going through these as well. It looked like he must have
[__] her, right? So, remember so gets through the
texts. Okay,
we got through the text. UTC plus C plus zero. Like, we got to
figure out a time zone. UTC. Let's see what else is going to
say here. UTC Is the Karen Reed stuff good? Is there actually
stuff to go over later? I'm not sure. I think there was some
good stuff in the first couple days. I wanted to at least watch
the defenses, as in Karen Reed's side. I wanted to watch her
o her defense's opening statements. Karen Reed was wild today.
I heard that and I haven't caught up on it yet. So, like I I
have to go catch up on it. I have so much content to catch up
on. I have so much work to do. I do have to catch up. I will
catch up and we'll get on it. I promise. I promise. I promise.
Plus zero. What time zone is that? None of that is proof she
wasn't. That's 100% true, King Gedra. And I I appreciate you
identifying that because that is true. Those were all funny texts
to read. It's very funny to read them. Um, none of those are
are even proof of an implicit engagement in like non-consensual
play, right? I think there are some things like that. There are
some texts where like she talks about it, but wanting somebody
to like do freaky with you is very very different from saying,
"I want you to ignore my statements on consent." Right? She can
say, "Hey, I want you to put me in a collar and like choke me."
That's her asking for it, right? It's very different from her
saying, "No, no, no, no, no. I don't want to you." No, no, no,
no. I don't want to do that. No, no, no, no, no. I don't want
to do that. So, so yes, that is important for us to realize and
keep in mind. Um, let's go. 6 a.m. UTC plus 0. What is that?
To your local time conversion. UTC plus 0. What? Uh, what is
it? GMT minus 8, which is where they were. It's like Miami, right?
It's East Coast time. GMT minus 8. Is it going to be East Coast
time? I don't know how to do this. It's
He's struggling.
GMTUS 8 is Pacific. Whoops. LA. Sorry, you're right. LA. It's
LA. It's LA. It's LA. My bad. My bad. My bad. It's LA. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. If it's plus Z Oh my god. I'm trying to figure
out what time it was. Oh, it's 11:00 p.m. Yeah, Shannon. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. So, 6:00 a.m. UTC. So, guys, don't forget to reopen
the Twitch. Okay. Reopen the Twitch. Oh, yeah. Sorry, the times
jumped around. The last times were April or sorry, January 1st,
2025, which would be around the time she was. And I noticed Shannon
did not include the texts, which do get included somewhere else,
of her saying like, "Hey, I didn't consent to you me in the ass
without a condom, right? UTC plus zero." So like they have plus
whatever, whatever. Yo, Shannon, if you're dating a 20-year-old,
Shannon posted this as proof. He didn't. All I'm saying is that
they didn't really do that. They didn't do that at all. No, they
didn't do it at all. All Shannon proved was like this woman once
wanted consensual with him. It seems like after after whatever
had happened with them. Okay. I think he lost a lot of control
of the relationship and he was like reaching out to her a lot
and it wasn't it wasn't looking as good. Okay. And you're telling
her it's too late at 11 p.m. Gang, check out of the 20-year-old
game. These is getting piped the out at 3:00 a.m. all type of
time of the night. You got to wake up to do a morning show and
you got night cap. You should have never been no 20-year-old.
Ain't no 20-year-old on earth go to sleep at no goddamn 11 p.m.
My [__] you are tripping, brother. So you're telling
me it's 11 p.m. and shorty talking about she want to get hogtied
and donkey and you're over here telling her it's too late? Shannon,
Uncle Shay Shay, you got to leave the 20 year olds alone. Leave
that for the YNs. You need a LMA a little older. The YN's I believe
that's the young ninjas. Okay, leave that for the young
ninjas. All right, I'm I'm actually going to end on Twitch here.
Uh thank you guys for watching on Twitch, okay, tonight. Thank
you. Thank you. I'm going to go ahead stop streaming on Twitch
so I can go back to my KCIP, full KCIP going forward. Thank you.
I should have done this earlier, but I didn't. So
it Who cares? Who cares? older woman who's in her 40s who got
who's I didn't think about this that like listen man you want
to you want to get up in the morning you got a morning you got
a morning show yeah you got a 20-year-olds aren't for you bro
they don't even get up until 4 p.m. or some okay. You think they're
getting pipe before midnight? No. Facing menopause.
She'll make you some tea and put some icy hot on your knees.
Some like that. What you you can't with no 20-year-old. I feel
like this is um this is something a 20-year-old told A, right?
I feel like some 20-year-old who was pissed at A told him these
things and now he's like just re-spitting them out at Ank. Cuz
Ax's only like 38, 39, 40, 41. Ank's like 53 and Axe just this
is what you see. This is like the Hassan thing where people call
Hassan old and then he has to call out everybody else who's old
and then those people have to call it other people who are old
and it's just like the age shaming thing and it's like dude I
don't care. I'm going to act how I feel. Okay. I feel like I'm
whatever age. That's how I act. I the shaming the age shaming
thing is just gross from people who are old. If you're age shaming,
you should be a 20-year-old. Okay. That's it. Like and like 20
like early 20s. Yeah. It's so weird to be like 30, 35, 40 and
being like, "You're you're pushing 50. You're pushing 40." Gross.
Yo, Chad. He's like 56. But he's like, to be fair, he is in like
the most immaculate shape of like any 56-year-old on the planet
Earth.
So, you know, back in what is it right before I bought this house,
it's like 2020, man. I remember I was [__] with this
chick. She was she was 20 about to turn 21. I ain't going to
cap her. My I witness I witnessed this chick not sleep for two
to three days. I couldn't believe it. But first of all, she was
taking some [__] I don't know where this [__]
my after a while I'm like, yo, I think I'm going to sleep. It's
It's yo, you got to realize when you getting too over this. It's
okay. You can't be a 20 year old and telling her 11 p.m. It's
over. Somebody said she was on an ex. I think that chick I was
told she was Yo, I seen the most incredible thing ever in life.
The chick popped so much my she cleaned my whole apartment. This
when I had I had she cleaned my whole apartment and didn't sleep
the entire night. I'm Bro, have you ever heard people who do
cocaine and do that? That's like um I've heard that story from
multiple people who do coke. They'll do coke and it's like they'll
do coke and then the plants get cancelled, right? And they're
like it I guess I'll just clean my apartment and then they actually
get like all of the cleaning done and they're like holy [__]
And then the the the statement I heard from this is basically
why a friend of a friend of mine told me they stopped doing Coke
forever, okay? Is because they they did Coke once, their plans
got cancelled, they stayed home, they cleaned their whole apartment,
they fixed every everything that was wrong in their apartment.
They did everything. And then the next time they kind of let
stuff pile up, they're like, "Do I just get like an eight-ball
and like crack this out?" And they're like, "Oh, that's actually
that's actually the worst thing I could possibly do." Nope. Never
touching that again. I can't. That's insane that I just considered
getting an eightball to like knock out my Sunday chores. Nope.
Never again. Never again. I've heard that story from two people,
which realistically is not like everybody, but it's crazy cuz
I only know very few. I only know like a handful of people who've
ever done Coke or who talk about doing Coke and it's like two
out of 12. Okay. Sleeping like a baby. I woke up. I'm like, "God
damn, I never seen my apartment this clean." I was like, "Did
you sleep?" She's like, "No, I ain't sleep yet." She didn't sleep
for two more days. I never seen that like that. Whatever drug
that is, this is that was probably meth. Yeah, that was probably
meth. Why Trump deporting all them the mother and putting tariffs?
You know why? Cuz whatever drug that was got to be illegal, money.
Ain't no way somebody should be up three days straight. That's
crazy. She took some that was like, it was a white girl. She
was cleaning my place like a Mexican. Real talk. No way. That
was a white girl. She's cleaning my place like a
Mexican. Oh, that was inappropriate. That was inappropriate act.
That was up. Was crazy. She ain't sleep for three days, gang.
I'll never forget that in my life. I'm like, this J sleep for
three days. Not a blink. Now, it wasn't Addy. It wasn't Addie.
I I think it was like Molly or some [__] Crazy. She
got with one of my and she went to Newark and coped it. Was like,
"Yo, you're you're cop." Oh, guys, I think we're we're off of
Twitch. Go over to the kick. Go over to the kickhat. I'm like,
"Yo, go over to the kick chat." I would even go to a fast. Go
over to the kick chat right now. Go over to the kick. Go over
to the kick chat. Thank you. restaurant in New York, man. What
the you coping just random? She's like, "Yeah, this one's this
one's shaped like a dolphin." What? Good luck. I said, "I'm going
just keep my drinking my little Hennessy over here and just the
chick ain't sleep." I ain't going to lie. She did so much laundry
she redid the laundry. She took it out of the machine out of
the dryer and put it back in the wash. I'm like, I never seen
my place that clean. This was right after I left um Angelica
left me or whatever. I was just I never seen so I was like, but
that's what happens when you deal with these 20-year-olds. They
might be off all type of I'm a grown ass man. See my don't get
it. What do you mean? Me I can't even hang with two chicks that's
too young. I'm lame for them now. You got these days on 50 perks
mollies Xanax. They smoking on 20 different things. I don't even
smoke hookah. You catch me. I'm only liable to be with some kas
amigos in my hand. I only drink. I'm like a outdated dinosaur.
Like this is why you know I said to myself I got to check out.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I don't want to skip this, but
there is like a whole Hassan segment we could do right now. That
would be crazy. I'm going to Listen, what I'm going to do is
I'll put it behind a donut goal. Okay, we got a whole Hassan
segment we could do tonight. The feud between him and Ethan and
some other stuff. Okay, I think put it behind like 20 subs or
something. Yeah, like 20 subs. We'll say 20. 20 subs or the equivalent.
Okay, 20 subs or the equivalent. Let me go like this. I'll put
it up. That 20 subs would be 100 bucks. That's cheap as Wait,
only 20. Uh 25 125. We'll do like this on segment. This on segment.
We'll do it after this. If we get more time. I don't know if
we're going to get more time. What do we got on the stream right
now? We got hour. Yeah, we can finish this in an hour. I can't
even Whoa. Mara, dude, thank you for the gifted sub. We can pee
no more. These is taking 20 pills, smoking all type of go to
sleep. They're walking zombies. I'm good. But Uncle Shay, if
you're going to sleep at 11:00 or not even going to sleep but
unavailable to the slank cuz she's requesting. Okay. She says
it's too late now. Huh? A acting like he knows about slinging
dick is crazy.
Oh man. Ain't slinging dick. Okay. Shannon Sharp slings. I don't
know if Ax slings. Okay. A is like a big guy. A kind of like
just gets the motion going. He lets like Inertia do the work.
Shannon Sharp slings. Okay, Shannon Sharp. Hold on. Shannon Sharp.
Uh, do I go gay on this? Do I just go Shannon Sharp shirtless?
This dude's in like insane shape. This dude is like 55, 56. That's
the shape he's in. At 54, that's the shape he's in. Okay. Shannon
Sharp knows about slinging. All right. Shannon Sharp knows about
slinging. A not as much. All right. This guy's in nutty shape
for his age. All right. A is not slinging dick. Don't compare
yourself to Ank. You ain't. You ain't an Shay. You'll never be
an Shay. Do not compare yourself to a legend. Why? And to get
up in a box. Anyway, she says, "I guess I Oh yeah, Shay, you
got tap out of this, bro. This is why you got to date your age
gang. I I guess I'm going to have to myself in the ass with my
dildo." Yo, Shay played that one correctly. She got so mad when
she said that and doesn't even respond.
lets it go. You know, I have no business on a 20-year-old if
this is how this message is going, gang. Come on, bro. That's
a has the exact wrong read on this. Like the totally wrong read.
She's like She's like desperate for him and he knows. I'm going to
I'm going to play this off. I'm I'm going to let this go. I'm
push this off. I'm going to wait. I'm going to wait on this.
And she's going to get even more desperate. I guess I'm going
to have to act. Don't get like Okay.
With a dildo now. When does that give her a good take? Well,
that is a good question. She says, "Follow me back on IG. I accidentally
blocked you." You know, that's
You know that's okay. He knows he's getting She was probably
posting something in her.
He gets back. Hold on. He gets back to checking out the uh the
Instagram. Shout out to my people over at Rumble, man. I love
y'all. Her pics bring her pics up
This guy's doing this guy's doing cube time again. He's just
like, "You know what? We got to check it out." And here, I can't
be blamed. It's a doing it. I'm not even in control. Okay. A
wants to go check out more of her pics. Yeah. I wonder what's
I mean I mean
25K. I don't know if we're at 25K tiers here. Okay. It's like
it's nice. It's not bad. It's good even. It's good. It's great.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on. This girl's like out of my league obviously,
but like 25K that's I don't know that I've seen 25K. Okay. I
don't know that I've seen 25K the the the ass that's worth 20
worth 25k per cheek. What y'all think she posted on only fans?
Ax's not doing an Only Fans review, is he? Dude, you guys are
insane. Some people in the chat called this girl a butterface.
You guys are so internet pill. Okay, actually yourselves you
guys in a not in a video game cuz we're not on Twitch. You She's
kind of a butterface. She's like, she's like a what y'all think
she ped posted on Only Fans. Bro, this girl's super cute. What
are you talking about? A butterface. What do you need? You understand
that? Like all of the all of the features, all of the edges in
this face that you're not expecting from an in that you're expecting
from an Instagram girl, those are all makeup. Her face isn't
mid at all. She's just not doing like super heavy makeup to make
herself look like a star. That's it. That girl's super hot. I
don't know what the you guys are talking about. Okay. I don't
know why Axe stopped to check that out. I'm I'm trying to get
through his texts here. He's got to get through the texts. Oh.
Oh. Oh, yes. Hold on. We got Night Cap from last night. Wait,
Oo, Oo, and Ank did Night Cap last night. There's no way. Ain't
no way they did Night Cap right after this, dude. Shannon Sharp
could have been a streamer, too. Shannon Sharp could have been
a streamer. He He like gets He gets sued for $50 million and
he's like, "You know what? Fire it up. Go live. Oo, go live.
We going live right now. I'll talk about it. I don't give a gets
it in. You remember when he uh when he went live on IG? He went
on IG live next day. UN gets it in. Gets it in. Gets it in. Night
cap. Hold on. Let's see here. Night cap. This is his and Oo show
21 hours ago, dude. NBA overrated players. Come on. Q&
But I think Oh, everyone out there. No, no. Luca played well
tonight. He played year two in Arizona. Come on. Come on.
In both of them. Hold on. What do we search the transcript for
lawsuit or something? Lawsuit. Lawsuit's in somewhere only in
the related videos. Uh, not lawsuit, but um
legal. Illegal. Gab. Nope.
controversy. Nope. Did they just not address it at all? He didn't
mention it at all. That's crazy. Shakedown. Yeah, but I It sounds
like he didn't mention it at
all. I didn't expect that. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. So, he's about
to go. Wait, no. No, that's for tomorrow. Wait, no, that was
for today.
A gets super late and just goes live. Axe just like pours like
4 ounces of alcohol, takes a shot, pours another three, and it's
like, "All right, let's do it. Let's go live. We got this 22.
I I know I do that. Oh, no. You scheduled right now. Oh, you're
supposed to go live right now. Oh, in a minute. Hey, Shannon,
I know you got me blocked on Instagram. It's all good. You could
unblock me, bro. You don't We're not no enemies, bro. I only
said you look zesty. You did look zesty. You feel what I'm saying?
Like, bro, you did look zesty, bro. Like, that's not no that
you should block me. You might be I mean, he basically always
looks zesty. He's like the black.
There's a reason that people were basically like he's so gay
that he faked an IG live a woman to make throw people off the
trail, make people think he's not gay. Getting a lot of people
making gay jokes about you, but like bro, like I don't even think
it's like that. And I think I'm looking at the situation fair.
I do like what you're doing. You have to work through this, right?
Like trust me, I ain't kind of want to be on stream when they
had some last about me. But I also understood the people that
do support you, they need to see you work through this. They
need to see the fact that you're not running and hiding cuz that
even looks even more guilty. You got to work through this. And
it's going to be tough, but you uh so I'll give the real advice
here. The real advice is no, you don't have to do anything. The
advice that a is giving a is literally saying, "Okay, listen,
brother. I need content. I need content and your content right
now. So stop holding back the content. Okay? Let the content
flow. Could you let the content flow? I'm pretty I'm pretty bored.
Could you go let the content flow? Talk about this. You can't
hide. You can't hide. You got to go live. You got to talk about
it. Realistically, A could or sorry, Ank could never respond
to this and it would make it would probably be better for him.
But A is just hoping hoping that Ank goes and uh yaps a little
bit more. You got to keep doing your live streams. You got to
keep working through this money. and um look like he's going
to do it because he's going to be on pretty much in a couple
minutes, right? All right. So, let's get back to it. She's already
doing the show tonight. So, I got I guess this is probably night
cap, right? Which, by the way, it would make sense if I'm thinking
about timing. She asked this. So, five All right, whatever. Anyway,
let's not He says yes. Then she says, uh, "Call me. I miss you,
daddy." This is January 11, 2024. Oh my god. She says, "Call
you back." Then she says, "K." Then she says, "I want to put
my tongue in your ass, then marry you." Sorry, I just want to
let that play again. We've We've gone through all the texts already.
All right, we went through them. App's going to do a little more.
Let's go to the live. Oh, yeah. Now, does Shannon Sharp still
do NFL game day stuff? He'll have to address it at some point
if so. No, he's on ESPN now, which is even crazier that he's
like he's like uh ESPN is way safer. Okay. They're like the Disney
related brand and he's on ESPN and he's got like multiple controversies
multiple controversies now over like several months. They don't
start on on time. Damn. They got 865 waiting now. People ready
to see what he Yeah. No, I don't think she's I think she's Hispanic.
Am I tripping? Oh, also, have I not seen her name anywhere? Listen,
I think conspiracy theory time. I think her last name is fake
and it does a lot to explain her fetish. Okay, her la her name
is Gabriella
Zuniga. Zuniga like uh hold on like this. Who's Gabriela Zuniga?
I Dude, are you really You're really going to You're going to
go out here? Dr. Umar was right. Okay, Dr. Umar was right. You
really going to have Shannarp's kids and have this last name?
Really? Karate Moses knows where I was going with
this,
dude? What? What? That's crazy. You can't have Shannon Zuniga
Jr., okay? That's not okay. That's not okay. That's not okay.
You can't have all these big black babies with that last name.
She is promoting racism with her breeding fetish. Okay. That's
crazy. Yes. Porter Beller. Yes. You cannot have You cannot have
Shannon Sterling and Jerome Zuniga. Okay. They cannot be the
starting offensive line for the Denver Broncos in 2020. Sorry,
2032. All right. No, 2042. They can't. That would be nuts. Okay.
It's f It's wild. It's It's just too much. I see where she's
going. I see what she's going for. Okay, I see what she's going
for and I reject it entirely. I reject it entirely. All right.
I'm also missing some of the texts. There's another one where
Shannon basically kind of owns up to what this could be, but
it's fine. We'll uh we'll keep watching. She's not white. I think
she's Hispanic, right? Is she Caucasian to y'all chat? I I I
have her as Hispanic. That's white. All right, let me do one
Google real quick. Zuniga
um ethnicity. This is Colombian. The Zuniga surname is of Spanish
origin. She's from Spain. She's Spanish.
Is it's also associated. Oh my god, I can hear Pluto just crying
like a girl upstairs. It's associated with the town
Estonia. You know, Pluto, my watch dog, so when I'm on stream,
he's over there just like, "All right, I'm about to have to bring
him in a little bit. That's my That's my love." Uh, okay. So,
it's associated with the Good lord, that dog is going off. Oh,
whatever. My dogs are starting to Yeah, I hear him crying. I
think I think that's uh Wait, wait, wait. I think that's what
Caesar said when he died,
right? Oh, I'm sorry. That actually just killed me. I'm myself.
I'm sorry. Uh, that's funny if you That's funny if you like Roman
memes. Okay. Okay. Hold on. Just one. We I don't think we got
this audio recording. You're coming to LA, which this one's like
a pretty This one's I think the one that they were threatening
him with to release. Well, what, Gabby? Well, you're coming to
LA
Yes. Well, I don't know why you want to go out. Don't worry about
it, Daddy. Well, okay. Okay. I'm not really interested getting
choked, so I guess we're going. Yeah, I might choke you in public.
Uh-huh.
Big black guy choke small white woman. It's not a Bro, this is
like uh this is like a Queenman stream right now with all the
dead air. What the is happening? Good look. [__]
It's not a good look, Shannon. Not a good look that you do what
the you did to me. To be honest, I don't even know that that's
a thing. I just know that's something people say about Queen's
dreams. I've never like seen that personally. I feel bad for
saying it. I just like played into a meme that I don't even know
really exists. Okay. Well, well, what? See, but when you listen
to that, is that Now, listen, Queen wouldn't apologize. I don't
care. Um, I'm Canadian. I'm Canadian. There's nothing I can do
about it. Um, that to me sounds like it's not him being abusive.
That sounds like he's trying to be like dominant, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. That sounds like he's trying to be dominant there.
That doesn't sound when I hear that. Now, none of this means
again, you have to hear the accusations around the right, which
maybe we'll pull up the complaint and see what what it says.
But that right there sounds like play to me. So, Shan Sharp's
accuser's lawyer has released new audio in which you can hear
the ESPN commentator threatening to choke the woman in public.
But the pro football hope pro football hall of famers team is
adamant is not what it sounds like. Attorney Tony Busby dropped
the file Wednesday morning and issued a statement saying Sharp's
attacks on him and his Jang do client were a big stupid mistake.
Busby goes on to say the audio provides a fair picture of the
relationship shortly before the alleged assault in the in this
case although he has not said what it was recorded. The clip
starts off while the two are apparently in the middle of a phone
call with Sharp's accuser asking the former NFL star if he's
coming to Los Angeles and he confirms he is. Uh, so this is the
the but I cried and said not to put it in my ass texts. Then
the accuser, who's allegedly 19 at the time she met Sharp, uh,
says she doesn't know why Sharp, who was in his mid-50s, would
want to go out on the town. Sharp tells her not to worry, and
the conversation soon turns into her getting choked. She tells
Sharp she has no interest in being choked, but Sharp seems to
ignore her. She says, "I might choke you in or he says, "I might
choke you in public. Big black guy chokes small white woman."
Let's look at the image again. Oh god. ESPN. Anyway,
continuing, she responds that it's not a good look, prompting
Sharp to accuse her of doing something to him, but it's not clear
what that is. The discussion ends with Sharp asking, "Well, what
Sharp's legal team insists conversations of this nature were
common in their relationship and don't indicate serious threats
of violence." They point to a text message which they say was
sent by do sharp in October 2023 which shows do asking sharp
to put a dog collar around my neck and choke me with it while
you're me crazy a rep for Sharp added this is a very small excerpt
with no date or context attached to it. As you know do filed
a lawsuit claiming Sharp in late 2024 early 2025. Sharp said
he was planning on suing the accuser for defamation and his attorney
Lanny J. Davis held a press conference Tuesday denying his client
did anything wrong and releasing a bunch of text messages claiming
that they show that she likes and asks for fantasy role playing
and other forms of unusual
Uh oh my god, a woman asked to be choked. That's crazy. That's
totally unusual. Uh virgin alert, Lanny J. Davis. Virgin alert.
Dude, does this guy not know that like it's 90 in not all but
95% of cases the people who engage and who introduce this kind
of play is the the female in the relationship? Okay, women are
groomers by nature. They will groom you into whatever they've
liked from before. Okay, men are innocent. Men just want to have
like a romantic relationship and then they realize this woman
like wants to be like wants these things to happen that they
they want no pardon. The man doesn't want to do that. the man
is like totally innocent and they get pulled into this like pit
of degeneracy. Now, that's not every time. And obviously, some
women probably pick it up from a guy, but listen, for me personally,
it was always the other way around. It's like, dude, I just want
to I just want to hang out. And then the woman's like, "No, hit
me in the head with this brick." And it's like, "You stop. Stop
talking about it. Stop doing that." Anyway, you guys know the
meme I'm talking about. Getting close to the end here of this
guy.
Calling just call So, but you know, it's very important like
she's not white. She's Spanish. No other text. Hey, I really
try to make Julius Randall make him go left. Make them go right.
Keep them out of way dominating. You try to watch the zero.
Got you. Head to Minnesota. Um the Lakers win 94 85. Series now
tied 1-1. Oh, Lakers won. Okay, that's good. And dude, like you
could not want anything and they'd be like, I want to date you.
Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah, guys. just want somebody who's going
to like love them. And women want somebody who's going to I you
know what? I'm not going to make broad statements. Never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Leaf sub 2. That's all I know in my life.
Okay. That's all I know. I'm not going to make broad statements.
Nope. Not going to trick me like that. Nope. Nope. Nope. You
lost. Whoever the people the voices in my head. You lost. Okay.
There's one other thing. There's a Pat McAfee and another guy.
Uh we have not hit. By the way, guys, we have a donation goal.
Okay. for more time on the stream. We're going to do the whole
Hassan segment. If you want to donate to that goal, I think it's
uh 20 subs. 25 subs or something. 125. I think that's 25 subs,
right? Yeah. So, if you want to start piling up towards that
goal. If not, we can end a little bit early. I've got some other
stuff to do. Anyway, that's okay. Uh let's watch the Pat McAfee
segment here real quick. There's just some guy who um suggested
maybe this isn't who ESPN wants on their network. Pat McAfee
was not a fan because if you don't know Shannon Sharp's a little
bit of an institution. I don't remember this guy's name. What
is this guy's name? Paul Haymon. Yes.
Who just donated? It's uh it's Stalin a sloth with five gifted.
Let's go. See CM Punk does as much to my reputation as Shannon
Sharp does to ESPN. Oh no. Jeez.
All right. See All right.
Oh, I don't really know who CM Punk is other than that they were
a wrestler at some point. But I think the point there is like,
hey, there's some who have been in my past and they me with my
reputation the same way Shannon Sharp with ESPN's reputation.
A lot going on. Don't be I'm not the one getting sued. Okay.
All right.
Wise man. You know what I'm saying? I am. Okay. So, if you guys
don't know, Paul or sorry, Pat McAfee has a big show on ESPN.
He's the other big name. It's like Pat McAfee and Shen Sharper,
the two big guys kind of come in after Skip Bis and Stephen A.
Smith and made a name for themselves. And maybe Bill
Simmons are like the big talk radio guys around sports. And I
think now Pat McAfee and Shannon Sharp have like come in and
are really beloved by people. And this is Pat McAfee show on
ESPN. And this guy comes on and says this. And ESPN's like, "Fuck,
we're looking to offer Shannon Sharp a bunch of money. Stop talking
about Shannon Sharp. They just had another heart attack." So
the tweet was, "What? Every executive just had a heart attack
and they just had another Hey, last night when the roast was
over and you and I were out back and you're going." So ESPN's
owned by Disney and they're like, "Do not talk about our$und00
million podcaster smoking weed. Stop. Stop talking about this
guy smoking weed. He doesn't smoke weed. He's got a clean image
as clean as Pat McAfee could be.
Puff puff pass.
You know what? Pat McAfee. That's a He's a selfish. Okay. How
about you pass a joint? Next time, next time you'll be a little
more generous,
Pat, right? And you're the wise man. You know Stephen A. Smith
really sucks,
This guy came on to just submarine Pat McAfee show. That's awesome.
Oh, you love to see it.
And I go, I love Stephen A. The man calls me the cult. The man
Stephen A. Smith, the army of the air. If there's one person
in the universe and I, Stephen A. Smith, at $70 billion a year
want to be. It's the wise man Paul Haymon. And you sit there
and you go, the bastards give me the same money as him or they
can. With that being said, dude. Oh, Pat McAfee's. You love to
see it. I didn't watch the whole segment. Maybe maybe it's better
after this. God damn, he's fat. He is, but he won. You can be
fat and win, turns out. How do you recover? Well, Pat McAfee
is never getting kicked out anyway, so he's fine. I saw that
Stephen A. Smith reacted. I've got the link. I've got the link
to the Stephen A. Smith video. I saw a little bit of it. It was
kind of boring. The only the interesting thing, more interesting
than the Steven A. Smith's actual video
was here. Let me pull this up. Was that first take might be at
risk, I think. All right, everybody, listen up. With all the
gamble, gamble on the gamble on the sports. Are you gambling
on sports yet, guys? Are you Are you gambling on sports? Don't
forget kick.com is backed by stake.com. Stake. US as well. If
you're in the United States, don't forget to bet on sports. Betting
on sports is incredibly important. Betting on sports is like
half of the US economy right now. Bet on sports. Bet on sports.
Bet on sports. Bet on sports. It's happening each and every day.
The Steen A. Smith Show wants to make sure you are taking advantage
of it all. That's why we've partnered with Prize Picks, the best
place to win cash while watching sports. The app is really easy
to use to make a lineup or download
of course iHeart Radio. Okay, as always, uh so if you don't know
who Stephen A Smith is, Stephen A. Smith is Sha Sharp's partner
on the first take podcast or morning show. So they do they shoot
a show show in the morning. They cover all the sports from the
previous night and it's incredibly popular. It used to be with
Skip Bis. It was better with Skip Bis, but Skip left for some
reason, right? Was it First Take was way better with Skip, right?
Am I crazy? Or was First Take like a thousand times better with
Skip. Skip and Shannon was way better to me than Stephen A. Smith
and Shannon. You guys don't think so? I thought so. Thanking
all of y'all for your support for watching the show and what
have you. the millions of downloads I received over iHeart Radio
subscribers now Eclipseing 1.18 million. Thank you so much for
the love and support.
Um, today is a different day because of where I have to get started
and where I have to finish. There's only going to be one subject
discussed today and it's where we're getting started. It's involving
some news that broke yesterday involving Shannon Sharp, my colleague
at ESPN and my friend. The Hall of Fame tight end was sued on
Sunday by a woman proceeding under the name Jane Doe. Pseudonym.
The 13page civil. Really? Pseudonym? You mean she wasn't actually
named Jane
Doe? What complaint filed in Nevada alleges that Sharp committed
assault? Assault. Battery. And battery. The plaintiff alleges
Sharps assaulted her several times at the end of 2024 and the
beginning of 2025. The suit also alleges that Shannon engaged
in the intentional infliction of emotional distress. It should
be noted that the suit was filed by attorney Tony Busby. This
is Oh god. Tony Busby who targets black men. Tony Busby, the
racist lawyer. The super racist lawyer who targets black men.
the same attorney that filed a suit against Jay-Z and P. Diddy,
alleging they both assaulted a minor, which has since been withdrawn.
JC Jay-Z also has counter sued Busby. By the way, the plaintiff
in a sharp civil suit is not the woman heard in the accidental
Instagram live stream. No, that's Michelle. And Michelle is the
one who set all of this off. She set off all of the content.
Oh my god. Incident. Oh my god. that made headlines last September
of last year. In response to the suit, Shannon and his legal
team went to social media yesterday and released a series of
allegedly explicit Guys, we
are 19 subs or a little bit of time away